[Music]
in the effective handling of men whose
wounds are of the mind and spirit
the battalion Medical Officers position
is unique he is a part of the outfit he
lives the life he intimately understands
the stresses he is an officer and yet a
physician if he establishes a reputation
for fairness and consistency his word
will be heated his explanations and
reassurances accepted his encouragement
of the man in coping with his fears
resentments and griefs can provide
stronger psychological support than any
other medical officer in the division
there is not much the individual
battalion medical officer can do to keep
men from injury in battle there is much
he can do to prevent important loss of
manpower from psychiatric causes
at first day I wasn't thinking much
about my contribution to the prevention
of any casualties except perhaps myself
I was uneasy I didn't know what to
expect
look doc there's your battalion
[Music]
regularly
I think it's your doctor yo that's right
am I glad to see you
yes I'm your relief you sure are a
little bad captain
[Music]
my name is Peter Tom Oberlin
thank you glad a nice
but I don't want to keep this taxiway
I'm going while
[Music]
you know Hera is me yeah
time doesn't store for some
disruptive gear here doctor all of one
of the corpsman take care of it okay C
Mon let's go meet the old man I'd heard
about Peters he was a good battalion
medical officer though not a
psychiatrist he seemed to have been
quite sold on the subject habit dr. Yost
he reported in the division and just got
here
Oh doc or berlin's replacement huh yeah
glad to have you aboard you're getting
into one of the best outfits on the line
it's a major part in my exec glad know
he's got a good bunch of men here doctor
I guess I thought a CEO and an exec in
combat would be rather taught and
brass-bound but these men and in fact
most of the officers I was to meet I
learned to respect for many reasons they
were tough professional soldiers highly
competent and assured but friendly and
receptive to any sensible ideas we had
to offer yeah the other day we were
talking about this combat fatigue
problem and the surge here says to me
without baton and I colonel there's a
direct relation between the quality of
leadership and the number of MP
casualties in any battalion first I knew
that there was nothing personal in it as
a matter of fact I I agree with him
completely although I'd never looked at
it in those terms before he wants more
he's been keeping a lot of man we
thought I'd gone psyched on I mean in
Theed cases and returning them to the
line
yeah the old professor showed us that
some of these Marines would look like
they couldn't take it were a really good
stuff it's surprising what a night's
sleep a little encouragement and getting
them back pronto will do for most of
them well we'll see you colonel right
well by the way surge able company may
have some rough going tomorrow they lead
the attack jump off at 0 6:30 thanks
major the words out we'll probably have
a few extra customers instant call
tonight well you know how to handle this
re yeah before doc Peters joined the
battalion sickbay unloaded too many good
men to the rear you can probably give
you some good pointers on this stuff and
we need all the men we can keep well
glad to have you with us thank you sir
Thanks
[Music]
can the sheet music Jim come on let's go
so this is it
yep say why all the emphasis on NP
casualties hi vote Marines were rugged
they are more than most but any man can
develop symptoms that make him
temporarily or in a few cases even
permanently ineffective in combat the
old man knows that he's pretty much on
the ball with this problem and that
helps
hi doc hi Andrews are you fine
here comes the adjutant
I joined is dr. Yost lieutenant Eastman
our adjutant doctor howdy-do
sorry major duck yellow clan right
doctor sorry do well bet dr. Oberlin was
glad to see you
he's been grassing by rotation for a
long time yeah I expect waiting for me
was beginning to get him down because so
by the way sergeant major took care of
that kid you sent in when it was all
shook up yeah thanks a lot just so I'm
scooting out of here well you said we
could all use an extra hand around the
CP after you sort of convinced it well
long that's all it took for most of them
I didn't realize it at first but the
sergeant major and the adjutant gave us
some wonderful help sometimes I couldn't
decide what to do with a man a couple of
days around the CP gave me a chance to
keep my eye on him most of them went
back to duty on their own when they were
rested and some needed a little
encouragement many men were kept at duty
who would have been lost to the rear we
had to be careful not to clog up the CP
or have sickbay known as an easy out
from duty we've gotta have cooperation
from the line officers I never miss a
chance to keep them informed of medical
problems concerning their men and
getting their angle on them particularly
NP cases it pays off incidentally what's
all this about dr. Oberlin
it was a hard charger and a damn good
doctor but lately the job seemed to be
getting him down he was getting a bit
Moody and let it influence the handling
of his patients what do you mean
sometimes he'd evacuate everybody and
sometimes he wouldn't evacuate anyone I
don't get you sometimes it almost seemed
to be if I can't get out nobody will
attitude and then other times it was if
I can't get out at least you can sure I
didn't think it out that way but it's
one of those things to get a watch in
yourself
get used to it after a while nobody
likes his stuff but it does become
tolerable how about some chow yeah oh
yeah I wasn't very hungry
and I didn't understand yet that this
was one of those opportunities Peters
had spoken huh I was meeting some of the
company officers for the first time a
few of them were down from briefing and
it stopped by the mess area before going
back to their men any marine officers
come out with you doc I was collecting
my relief any minute now no sorry
quit kidding yourself milk your relief
just graduated from grade school how the
women making out of the states these
days do they miss me oh they sure do one
of the sprained ankle how's he doing
well we've had him sitting around the
supply tent making out forms another few
days and he'll be good as new what about
that feller I sent down with the drizzly
runs we corked him up it's probably more
of an emotional thing than infectious
another 48 hours around the CP and he'll
be okay
you better keep your eye on him though
I'm not sure he can take much more oh
why not evacuate him we've got fighting
to do up here
cool Jack anybody can get a belly full
some sooner than others so what he won't
be any good to me even if you do get him
back on the line wait a minute Pete send
us back plenty of men I never thought
we'd see again they perform - that's old
mate the equivalent of a couple of
platoons of Co said makes a hell of a
lot of difference
I haven't noticed too many of these
characters returning to my platoon maybe
there's a reason
hey Pete what percentage would you say
of all our casualties are sent back to
your division psychiatrist it depends on
the situation
and have you prolong combat and where
we're getting crowded or have to move
out quick maybe one out of six or seven
wounded well suppose you have the time
in space and pens
practically all of the men who were
stuck even before they get into the
battle or sent back to duty promptly
those men who do break in battle and
need a little more time we called for a
day or two most of these men get back on
the lines too what about the division
psychiatrist they send back well over
half of the men we do have to evacuate
yeah but how many of them only crap out
again believe it or not only a very
small percentage see what I mean look
after competition doctor seems like
we're all turning into a bunch of
psychiatrist you know that's very
interesting because whether you realize
it or not you hit it right on the head
the tune leaders can be our biggest
tough in this whole problem hell I'm not
trying to be a chowderhead about this
thing I'm open-minded and only slightly
[ __ ] well anybody who's been out here
long enough is likely to notice some
changes in himself goes off his feet a
bit it's a little sour irritable how
long have you been out here jack okay
okay time for sick call look why don't
you get squared away and I'll see you
there finish your coffee though okay Oh
doc what about that ammo carrier I sent
down to the weeps one who said he got
pooped out carrying Emma on the hill it
looked kind of shook Murphy yeah I
thought he was genuine enough not a very
rugged time for better mature we gave
him a little rest in a pep talk told him
you might be able to make him a rifleman
okay doc thanks for the referral thanks
for the referral lines seem to have
picked up the lingo but I had begun to
see that it went a good deal deeper than
that Peters was getting cooperation by
proving that there could be an unnoticed
and unnecessary leakage of manpower if
company officers didn't understand the
problem of combat anxiety in its many
and varied forms
there they are the many and varied forms
I didn't know then that combat anxiety
might show up as it a sprained ankle
that stayed lame a well healed wound a
pair of broken glasses two things
Peter's got right at the core of things
I told you business would be up tonight
the truth is many if not most of these
men wouldn't be here if we weren't
attacking in the morning their symptoms
are real but they're scared this plane
scared and most of them don't connect
their symptoms with being scared it's
normal
look I'll lead off and you can take home
when you feel like it huh
will do Oh doctor yeah lieutenant I sent
this man in says he wants to see you his
name's Johnson oh yeah
what's the trouble Johnson doc stomach's
all fouled up out of the body it feels
lousy all the time all the time on and
off for a couple of weeks so sick when I
wake up off my feet then belching rotten
eggs
quivery feeling all the time any pain no
man everyone out here starts belching
rotten eggs after a while I was the sign
of an old song put your head back
with that first sick call I started to
understand the various signs and
symptoms of anxiety that are common to
all men who have been in combat for any
length of time I was to find that there
were many men and officers whose
stomachs acted up forehead headaches
palpitation loose bowels frequency airs
ability tremors or whatnot yet who were
completely effective in their jobs it's
not the symptom it's the man his
capacity for adapting to the stress of
combat despite his anxiety nothing
unusual fella most of the men get the
same feeling from time to time you ever
played football yeah well you know the
feeling you get just before the game
this is the same thing only a hell of a
lot more so the corpsman will give you
something to ease the bouncing you'll be
okay
that hope so doc
what's his temperature normal doctor
doctor did you take a look at Jasper
down here had a headache the last few
weeks it says I'll go
this is a man doctor yes you want me to
get your Thomas cope sir yeah and then
Jasper
there was one marine as seem to know he
was scared and hoped his headache would
somehow get him off the lines I didn't
realize that at the time because in the
beginning I was inclined to spend too
much time trying to rule out unlikely
organic causes that's a luxury of
civilian practice later I'm afraid I may
have become a little too casual in a
diagnostic sense the best approach of
course is to take the man and his
complaint seriously whether psychogenic
or not and to conduct as sufficient of
physical examination this time permits
even if some conscious elaboration is
suspected it's not only good medical
practice but to do otherwise provides
the man with a convenient basis for his
resentments and a rationalization for
any reluctance to carry on you stand by
I'll be back in a minute
there that should fix it up thanks doc
hey I've got a man here it says he's had
headaches for a couple of weeks I can't
find anything except a little nasal
congestion I think we oughta send him
back for some ENT study what's his name
Jasper again huh Abel company let's see
if we can get some more dope on him
we'll give him a ring
Table six please
Table six let me talk to your company
commander
Oh Jack this is Peters look Jack I got
one of your men down here named Jasper
do you have any scoop on him yeah I know
him Pete rabbit II sort of character but
kind of surly keeps to himself sloppy
with a detail I think he's a foul ball
how long has he been with you about 10
days they look Jack I've talked with
this guy before he's not a bad short
basically among other things have been
worrying about home matter he's new and
he's not the sort to adjust to a new
crowd very quickly give him a chance
how about getting sergeant gray to show
a little interest in him you would help
do oh brother
what's the Marine Corps coming to okay
okay
send him back well do what we can now
cooperate for the work as before in
similar cases once a new man starts
feeling is a welcomed member of the
organization he doesn't feel so scared
and unhappy but you have to act before
the things out what do we do now
give him some explanation about these
headaches a few a PCS to take with him
and send him back to duty kindly but
firmly and don't get involved in any
arguments
what's up man maybe got the pile doc
let's take a look
ah just a few tags we can fix that up
for you for the time being anyway I
should rather go to the hospital
hell no sir it ain't that bed I can't
leave the outfit now we're jumping off
in the morning can't you just put
something up there okay
the corpsman will give you something to
ease it that group spirit is the most
powerful support the doctor has in
keeping men at duty some men you just
can't evacuate even though you know it's
medically sound and some won't even turn
in when they should as long as the
Fighting's going on well I guess that's
all of them for sick call this evening
Carmen will take care of anything else
that comes up that they can't the chief
of let us know okay well we sure have a
good bunch of corpsman we do for that
matter the aid men out with their
companies take care of Moses they call
right on the spot well I expect they
know how to help with organic troubles
but are they have any value with these
combat fatigue cases oh they sure are
and you take those corpsman over there
when they report for duty I always give
them a briefing on the NP problem the
necessity for preventing the leakage of
manpower and at the same time spotting
the occasional anxiety cases becoming
useless in a danger to adopt it but it
just won't call it quits
above all I emphasize the company aid
man's great value in providing observant
information on all the referred cases to
help us make a fair decision about this
position you'll see what I mean in the
morning when the real show starts
[Music]
softening up the magician before Templar
[Music]
[Music]
morning sometime
[Music]
got about an hour before the casualties
start coming in time to wash and get
some breakfast people have things set up
in a few
[Applause]
nothing serious fella have to send you
to the rear for a while off okay sure
it'll need to sutures you can go back to
your outfit now
what's that felt weird Ikhwan aids land
it right next to me didn't get you
though nah but a wing like the tomb
sergeant
I started Halloween I guess I got
excited for a while
good god doc I don't know I I guess I
can make Corman have a coffee here
the man was alert responsive not unduly
exhausted the reaction was relatively
superficial and trenchant to evacuate
him to the rear might have sent up a
guilt reaction that he would have had to
justify by the development of further
symptoms he'd been thrown off balance by
a sudden shaking experience we gave him
a chance to get his bearings offered him
some firm reassurance and sent him right
back
[Applause]
how about some water huh
[Applause]
nope
thanks I just crapped out going up the
hill on attack been up all night not all
day on patrol yesterday I was pooped
scared like I never been before even get
my breath
I guess I just passed out I could just
sleep but I can't
doze off like can I jerk awake take it
easy fella how about rocking this man
out near sick bay I don't expect to move
in the next 12 hours
what if he doesn't snap out of it by
then well we can always send him back a
regimental aid and have them hold him
for another 24 hours
we sent a note along indicating we
expect a man back shortly
we've got a good working relationship
with regiment on these cases they know
how to handle the occasional man we send
them by regimen why not back to the
division second trees well if you think
there's a chance for a fairly quick
recovery you should use the regimental
aid station one you can't hold the man
here he gets back on the job quicker
still a part of the fighting element of
the division and then he doesn't get the
feeling of being a hospital case I see
Peters was hitting upon the basic
principle of combat psychiatry treat as
far forward as reasonable and returned
to duty as quickly as possible in that
way you don't lose the great advantage
of the man's identification and pride in
his own fighting group and you minimize
the opportunity for symptoms to develop
and persist as unconscious justification
for escape now you take that boy looks
much worse than the others yet most of
this is due to physical exhaustion and
lack of sleep to factors which can often
mislead you into a bad prognosis
he's from Mabel company they've really
been kept jumping lately well give him
just enough sedation to knock out the
anxiety and permit him to sleep that may
do the trick doctor yours
it's only a flesh wound fella
[Applause]
what happened to you son grenade bounced
off my helmet went off knocked me dizzy
you remember the sound of the explosion
the flash yeah never forget it
I'm mr. hash start right after headache
dizzy
let's have an otoscope
blast concussion it I don't think so
it will see that hurts you fast little
it was not blast concussion I gradually
discovered that the familiar symptoms of
headache trans indigenous and various
acute anxiety manifestations after a man
had been shaken up by a nearby explosion
were usually best understood and treated
in Psychological terms in most cases
brain injury due to concussion was minor
or absent there was no true retrograde
amnesia no hemorrhages no tympanic
perforation no neurological findings
that hurt huh well give him a mild
sedative stat and get regiment to keep
him for a few days before sending him
back to his outfit we can't keep him
here because we might have to move on
nothing at all serious fella nothing
wrong with your head you'll be okay in a
few days but you do need and deserve a
couple of days of rest and sleep Carmen
this is Ana back to regiment on me
well you lucky going to the rear
sleeping attack all day come on bring
your child to you boy that's for me I
won't even have to do my own laundry
yeah you so let's get all the breaks
what is here last name first name killer
face
any spirit knows what's the story
corporal corporal do you hear me what's
the story
thousands of damn good common we always
get useful information from him that's
some coffee
corporal I left Oh God you need a rest
corporal we'll go back but you need a
rest I crapped out what set me back send
me back I belong here I'm not sick they
need me up there go back with them a few
days back oh man get this man into tight
not much less more than you might think
I know that man but out here for a long
time I had just about all he can take
for a while
funny I always thought a man would be
glad to get out of this mess
not that one apparently that's just this
and I can't keep it up any longer why
they feel guilty of letting their
buddies down well we can tell them what
good guys they are have it what do we do
to treat him well we reassure them as
best we can
most of the men we see have these
feelings to some degree but in extreme
cases like that one why the guilt relief
business has to wait until it calm down
back at the medical company with
division psychiatrist Oh doctor we need
some help
I better do a cut-down I don't want to
waste time
it looks pretty clean chipper mountain
all right doctor
hey Doc my feet are killing me how long
since I've been here that's four months
now
so you got a new pair of boots they give
you any support I did it first then the
pain came back have a look
pretty good-looking pair of dogs Daisy
but they hurt doc Oh
i fella
what happened
let me have your wet it's okay
sure come on let me have you wet
we're gonna send you to the rear fella
you need a rest you'll be okay
certainly this man looked bad yet not
all such cases are irretrievably lost
even for further combat duty although he
had to be evacuated to division there
were some favorable indications he had
performed well before his disturbed
behavior was precipitated by a sudden
shocking experience he still had a good
fighting grip on his weapon most shaken
men are sent to duty by the [ __ ] or the
division psychiatrist but there are a
few who for the safety and welfare of
the group should never be returned to a
frontline unit the panic prone the
grossly immature the profoundly
apathetic the faltering noncom who has
lost the confidence of his men and
severe hysterical reactions when not
precipitated by some sudden trauma hey
doctor hi Tony
you're still here
because the zoo commanders outfit so
it's top was telling me last night
the man yes sir good producer man's hard
to get
look I know your feet father if it you
can carry on catching I don't know
look why don't you come and see me when
we're in reserve then we can get a
specialist to look at you I don't think
there's anything serious stay loose yeah
okay
okay son we'll take that stitch out
tomorrow dr. Peters yeah
three just called we're moving up at
1830 thanks Steve you hurry you can get
your buddy
they need a man up there can handle a
bazooka
we're moving up at 1800 yeah I know
hey Tony come on buddy
let's go
[Music]